♪ Happy Dappy Bird ♪
♪ I love Dappy Bird ♪
♪ I have no life,
and I'm dead on the inside ♪
♪ Happy Dappy Bird ♪
Hey!
Why'd you throw away my phone?
Because it's up to us
to counterbalance the damage
that Woody is doing
to this planet.
We've got to go green and cut
our carbon footprints to zero.
Can I at least keep
my vibrator?
It's green.
I'm pretty sure it was white
when you bought it.
I feel like we've made
some good progress here.
I can feel Mother Earth
healing.
[engine revving]
[parade music]
(Woody)
Hey, Ethel, how do you like
my "global warming's bullshit"
parade?
Yay!
A parade!
Shut up, Connie.
This whole thing is
a "[bleep] you" to me.
What makes you feel
that way?
That sign does.
[laughing]
Every float expands
my carbon footprint,
including the Woody Johnson
musical farting cows.
[cows farting 1812 Overture]
[laughing]
Now, how can that
not put a smile on your face?
- I hate cows.
- What? How could you hate cows?
There's something off
about them.
They're always watching us
with those dead eyes.
It's like
they're planning something.
You scared of cows!
I'm not scared of cows.
Well, let's go say hello.
No, no, no!
[laughing]
Hey, everybody,
Malloy's scared of cows!
Okay, maybe a little.
But it's
because of my animal instinct.
I have heightened senses.
Trust me,
I don't want this gift.
[sniffs]
Connie, it's going to be
a heavy flow day.
(Connie)
Thanks, Malloy.
Well, I think cows
are cool,
especially ones
that can fart Mozart.
[farting Symphony Number 40
in G Minor]
[laughing]
Oh, Ethel,
you should see the look
on your stupid fa--
Ahh!